hi there steve kaufman here the linguist
on language
uh today i want to talk about
teaching credentials particularly
language teaching credentials
we have
tessel teaching english as a second
language
and other credentials that
many many people
study for and acquire
and these are very useful in terms of
getting jobs as teachers
but my interest is
how important is it from the perspective
of the learner how important is the
teacher's credential
in determining whether the teacher is
effective
my belief is that the teachers
credentials are not important at all
however
it's certainly the case that the
teachers
place great value on these credentials
and whenever
the results of teaching for example
language teaching
say in the case of uh
immigrant language teaching in canada i
was speaking to the the government
department in the immigration department
that looks after teaching of immigrants
and they were saying that
that they haven't they aren't having
much success and one of the things
they're going to do is raise the
credential standards and
more money on training and so forth and
this is inevitably what teachers like to
do they would like to see more money
spent on training
more money spent on creating more jobs
but from the perspective of the learner
i don't think the credentials matter at
all
and i was reading a book on my kindle
called liberating learning
technology politics and the future of
american education written by two
academics terry moe moe and john chubb
and one of the interesting comments in
there was
that a variety of of different uh you
know research
has shown that credentials have very
little bearing
on
the results in education generally and
i'm sure language education is no
exception
uh what seems to matter the most is the
verbal ability of a teacher the ability
of the teacher to speak well in an
interesting way engage the students
that's the number one thing
the second thing is the competence
that the teacher has in the subject
and the third thing is the experience
of the teacher
so if we apply that to language teaching
uh obviously the ability to speak the
native language is extremely important
and even if it's a non-native speaker
the ability to speak the language is
extremely important the second thing is
the competence
and here i think we're talking about
a and ability to speak the language well
and second of all as a language teacher
the experience of having learned
one or more foreign languages
and third of all in so far as experience
i hear again it's the experience of
teaching which i think is extremely
important more important than any
credentials
and second of all again the experience
of having learned a language so i think
all of these things are more important
now is the teacher important period well
i think that the teacher can be
extremely important even in my own case
even though i am very much an
independent learner and i think people
should be independent learners and the
best language learners are independent
learners
somewhere somebody has to turn that
switch on now for some lucky people
they just as youngsters get very
interested in other cultures and other
languages but most people are at some
point influenced by someone else
that someone else can be a teacher
and in my own case at the age of 17 at
mcgill university it was a french
professor who turned me on to french
culture and the french language and that
made me an independent learner initially
of french and then of other languages
so i think the teacher can be a
tremendous influence the teacher is an
influence in terms of
motivating the learner and so there we
get to the sort of verbal skills
communication skills of the teacher
competence and therefore confidence in
teaching the language and of course
experience as a teacher and as a learner
all of these things
make it more likely that that teacher
will be a positive
influence on the learner turn on the
learner
credentials
learning how to theoretically how one
should teach modal verbs and when i mean
that's to my mind irrelevant there are
textbooks you can either follow the
textbook or not follow the textbook it's
my experience that any textbook i have
seen that seeks to teach
certain parts of speech in certain order
and expects the learner to learn them
are doomed to failure anyway because the
learner is going to learn them on their
own timetable and as i've said before
learn primarily through massive input i
mean we've built the link system around
the idea that if you listen a lot if you
read a lot if you save and review a lot
of words and phrases you will gradually
get used to the language and you can at
your own speed
review some grammar points in a small
book uh googling on the internet or in a
grammar class it doesn't really matter
but it's not crucial it's not essential
to your learning of the language and
what the teachers tend to do
they
reinforce one of the most unfortunate
habits and attitudes of learners and
that is the feeling that they have to
nail things down they have to learn it
chapter one i have to learn chapter one
for my teacher for my test i have to
learn chapter two if i can't remember
the words if i can't remember the
grammar then there's something wrong
with me it's pressure it's all of that
is very unpleasant and it comes from the
teachers and that's what they're taught
to do
in terms of getting their
their certificates
i i should say i've never been to one of
those courses but i assume that that's
what they are taught to do because
that's what they do when you go to their
classes so
in summary then i think that credentials
are not important i think there's a
very unhealthy insistence on credentials
throughout the education system
i think that the analysis and and
basically the conclusion of these two
authors chub and mo
based on research
that it's more a matter of verbal
ability ability to communicate
competence in the subject and of course
personality plus some experience these
are the things that make successful
teachers successful teachers turn on
learners they don't insist that learners
do this for this test learn these
chapters because i taught it this
semester
all of those kinds of things and
many of the explanations that i get from
the experienced credentialed teachers
are unwelcome i don't want them what i
want is an engaging person that's going
to turn me onto the language so
not surprisingly i'm not a fan of
credentials and i think credentials are
only one part of the sort of rigid
structure of of language education
which is the reason why so many people
are turned off language learning
so i look forward to
your comments thank you